Сам я херсонський.
Коли я одружився, то ми переїхали сюди.
Вісім років прожили тут, а зараз живемо в Херсоні.
От коли ми сюди тільки переїхали,
то я почув такі звуки дивні, наче насос качає.
До того ж рано-вранці, десь о шостій ранку.
Ми о шостій прокидаємося, щоб на роботу їхати.
І я питаю в дружини:
«Чого фермер так рано насос вмикає і воду звідкись качає?»
А вона каже: «Це не фермер, це бугай».
Я думаю, що таке бугай? [Cміється]
Вона мені пояснила,
що це такий птах, що живе в очереті.
А потім ми організували клуб історичний.
Таку реконструкцію.
Зробили костюми, предмети козацькі.
І через декілька років мій товариш-музикант,
скрипаль, каже: «Треба зробити бугай».
Думаю, який ще бугай? Я чув, що є така пташка,
а що ще яийсь бугай є, я навіть й не знав.
Ну я так почитав, подивився картинки,
але там не було опису, як його робити.
Було тільки зображення і опис, що це басовий інструмент,
який використовується разом з іншими інструментами.
Вони дають мелодію, а він — ритм.
Його вважають українським народним інструментом.
Хоча до нас він прийшов з Європи,
і в Америці він також є.
Є різні конструкції.
Вже за чотири дні я зробив перший свій бугай.
Це ми бачимо вже корпус готовий.
Тут товщий, тут звужується.
Завдяки цим залізним обручам він тримається.
Шкіру ми замочуємо приблизно на добу.
Якщо вона пересохла, то можна і більше.
Так само і кінський хвіст, його теж треба намочити.
Бо його треба зав'язати вузлом, а на суху він не зав'язується.
Такої товщини для гри достатньо.
Можна щоб він був і товщим.
Я інколи бачив, що і такі використовують, та це зайве.
Такий важко хапати. Для гри достатньо тоненького.
Волосся я використовую з монгольських коней.
Хвіст беруть не від кобилиці, а від коня.
Це не сексизм.
Просто кінь пісяє вперед і хвоста не замочує.
І волосся в нього якісніше.  [Сміється]
Щоб закріпити хвіст, треба пришити таку шайбу.
Точніше, дві.
Основну знизу і додаткову зверху.
Мембрана — це основне джерело звуку.
Вона як динамік. Від її вібрацій видобувається звук.
А для того, щоб вона вібрувала, потрібен хвіст.
Коли рука по ньому ковзається,
то виходить наче боротьба:
ми тягнемо його вверх,
а мембрана повертається назад.
Щоб був звук, треба щоб рука була волога.
Для того, щоб відбувалося ковзання.
Цьому бугаю десь років п'ять.
У нього вже трошки висмикався хвіст.
Якщо зараз пташку цю спробувати показати,
то она буде ось така.
[грає на бугаї]
Ось так вона робить три рази.
З такими ж паузами між цими звуками.
[грає на бугаї]
[спів пташки]
О, включився.
П'ять разів там хтось сказав.
Другий бугай мене попросив зробити профессор ботаніки.
Він хотів навчитися на ньому грати гімн України.
Я його часто бачу, але забуваю спитати,
навчився чи не навчився.
Один бугай ми подарували
Херсонському училищу культури.
Ми з ними співпрацювали.
Вони не просили, але ми подумали,
що добре було б, якби у них був бугай.
А потім наше херсонське телебачення
зняло маленький ролик на три хвилини про те, як я їх роблю.
І після цього я втратив спокій.
Люди з інтернету стали писати і просити бугаї.
Я їх ніколи не робив, щоб заробити гроші.
Коли мені подзвонили і сказали,
що їм потрібен бугай маленький у Британію,
і я сказав, що маленький коштуватиме гривень 200.
Там довго сміялися, на тому кінці слухавки.
До речі, незважаючи на те, що це, на державному рівні
визнаний, наш національний інструмент,
люди, коли його бачать, абсолютно не впізнають.
Думають, що це щось африканське.
Як ним користуватися, також мало хто знає.
Завдяки освітній роботі у Херсоні
(ми декілька разів на рік на усіляких
святкових заходах пропонуємо людям грати),
вже знають деякі херсонці цей інструмент.
Та як ним користуватися.
Бо починають стукати як по барабану,
щось з цим хвостом робити теж не знають.
Я коли перший барабан зробив,
заховався в гараж, щоб людей не лякати.
А він такого великого діаметру був.
Повибігали сусіди і я чую, баби кажуть:
«Дощ збирається».
Вони подумали, що це грім.
А потім, коли зробив перший бугай,
то вже заховався не в гараж, а в літню кухню.
Почали собаки гавкать.
Ну я стараюсь вже так сильно людей не лякать.